okay guess we're jumping right in this
this is September 1999 there was
literally almost zero there's no menu
action at all at all I don't know I
didn't anything wet this came other then
it's like a horror game that's literally
yet I think the game I think they said
the last like five minutes okay look an
idea it is a beautiful game though it's
crazy because like if this was not
having this VHS thing it would not look
as good to be honest with the VHS it
looks like this is like a real live
video like this is insane
let's see here a lot of hesse had a
headache get it yeah go this way - what
the [ __ ] right he drinks a lot of beer
man this is well-crafted holy [ __ ] even
the [ __ ] noise of walking over there
is that can I do much can I do I can't
do that what the [ __ ]
it's still rolling there's a knife right
there all right look I see what's in
here
can I go in here OSR can I go in here no
sir can I do anything with Kim nothing I
could do [ __ ] in here this house doors
well the time is ticking so I gotta be
able to do something oh okay
apparently right trigger like flips it
to next scene I guess so this is [ __ ] I
don't look at the date I think this is
one day later maybe so what's changed
nothing hey hey
they don't [ __ ] sound knocking can I
help you sir can I help you okay I still
can't go through any of that anyway
that's what the bed was like again
hopefully it's not a [ __ ] pigsty like
last time Kenzi okay oh the parents are
kissing [ __ ] all right I guess what next
day okay so it's September 19th what at
1:00 a.m.
now okay actually I don't open Oh cops
what two days later so right tricker
doesn't do anything it just zooms in I'm
here sir he keeps you kick kick okay
[ __ ] you but if that door he's gotta
love [ __ ] wait did you say hey sir
can you see me what the [ __ ]
see what this looks like holy [ __ ]
okay I can't stinky I figure I can still
hear it
here's crying that's somebody we got
somebody who did this
yeah if I could love my parakeets okay
okay yeah at least thing I think that
sense of a plastic down otherwise you'd
[ __ ] stain the floors he expected a
positive excerpt because that's not how
you get your deposit back
no the bird days he moved one we're
doing a birth thing go that's over here
yes right what is that hello sir hello
sir
oh dear it's been like like a week so if
probably like Barry's thing yeah there
if he isn't claimed by now
he's thanking
[Music]
[Music]
that's it
well that was one interesting game I
thought it was very well done
probably must have known his strengths
and everything you know like you could
be really good really good at him making
environments and then just really bad at
meeting character rink especially men
were like the better you get at beacon
people the more like you get the uncanny
valley stuff so he did very well done it
wasn't like it was just really nice yeah
well Donna I hear he's making a full
sequel or some like that called so like
December 2000 they think that sure do
you look out for it awesome anyway
thanks for watching y'all see you on the
next one